[Music]
the presidential race is getting very
nasty have you noticed that heavy doses
getting particularly nasty well today a
political analyst for CNN compared the
level of bickering between the two
presidential candidates to fighting on
the Real Housewives shows yeah yeah
after hearing this President Obama said
don't blame me blame that lying [ __ ]
Mitt Romney they throw champagne at each
other a lot Olympics have been very
emotional do you find them emotional and
II uh yeah I guess a little bit you know
and as much as the meds allow me to feel
anything
I'm so shockingly honest I can't believe
it
oh I'm sorry yeah who a study they just
took a study a study shows that 16% of
Olympic gold-medalist cry on the podium
yeah meanwhile 1% of bronze medalists
get an erection
yeah a story a German Olympic diver did
one of the worst dives ever and he got a
score of zero point zero yeah he tried
to save face though halfway through the
dive he yelled cannonball in Russia and
have you heard about this story a
President Vladimir Putin is being
challenged by a feminist rock group a
punk rock group called [ __ ] Riot yeah
by the way little fun fact [ __ ] Riot
was the name they almost went with for
the view
[Applause]
take it
[Music]
judging by your reaction they missed a
huge opportunity also just Barbara
Walters Whoopi Goldberg get the chance
to hear Barbara Walters I heard this the
Jersey Shore's Pauly D reportedly made
eleven million dollars last year yeah so
the lesson here is kids don't stay in
school it's a huge waste of your time
drop out now and get a job on [ __ ] Riot
good show can't believe this story in
Pennsylvania a burglar broke into three
homes and performed oral sex on three
sleeping men charges are being pressed
by no one
[Applause]
[Music]
who's that evening work it's a it's up
to someone's this is a cover-up story if
somebody walked in on oh it was a guy
doing their towel when you're done I'm
gonna yell yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
ten more minutes maybe mad